hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent game to share with you from
round two of the 2023 Qatar Masters on
the white end alisher simanov playing
against Magnus
Carlson so let me first begin with the
elephant in the room Carlson's opponent
wore an analog watch during this game
and that rattled
him uh sparked a big discussion here are
some of the tweets that that helped to
tell the story I think what mvl had to
say is on point if You' like to go ahead
pause the video read up on this all you
want my main focus in this video is
going to simply be on the
chess okay this game begins with
D4 and the opening we work with B6
Queen's Indian
defense A3 pan variation no Bishop B4
check check Carlson put some pressure on
C4
defended and black says mission
accomplished I got what I wanted this
little finesse with the bishop has
pulled the queen away from supporting a
D5 Advance that's not to say D5 still
can't be
played um it could still be played as a
Gambit all right Knight C3 C5 E4 you see
the threat it's a positional one given
time white would like to next play D5
form a little triangle and have the
bishop bite on a rock black is well
aware of this timely breaks up the pawn
Trio only after the structure has been
addressed does black continue to develop
Knight
F3 okay the followup is Knight C6 a
question I had for myself is what
happens if black goes after F2 or in
other words what's happening after
Knight G4 how to
defend you might think well I could drop
my knight back here you don't have to
run in Reverse though a good move for
white in this position is Bishop G5
hitting the queen and after F6 the
bishop is there in
time there is a more sophisticated
variation and that is to capture on F2
right now this is not a good path for
black how would this one play out we
would end up with a queen exchange and
white is down the exchange however this
guy is cornered and in time white is
going to win the Knight soon we're going
to have a two minor pieces versus rook
in
bounds very good for white so in this
game it is simply more
development space for white on the queen
side with Tempo the reply Bishop E7
what's very important to note is that if
if black instead drops the Knight into
D4 don't take the Knight if white takes
the Knight on D4 the bishop would be
invited to an excellent diagonal there's
all of a sudden a pin there's a problem
on e4 F3 has its own issues Knight H5
Queen H4 with
check okay how should white play if
Knight D4 move the queen right away not
with the intention to meet Knight takes
Knight with Queen takes Knight because
the bishop would be able to get to D4
the idea is to take on the double F
pawns and look at this G7 square there's
some coordinated pressure here and
queenside castles is right around the
corner a very Lively position ahead to
be
sure okay in this game Bishop E7 Bishop
B2 Black's Queen has a an ey on the E5
push he's working from afar going to C7
is asking for
trouble all right Rook
D1 black
castles and the followup is Bishop to E2
E5 is close to maybe working as a pawn
sacrifice but do know if you play E5
right now after these captures the queen
gets to take with check I bring this up
it's variation up because once Bishop to
E2 is in there this becomes a thing if
the queen isn't able to get here with
check there's a trick for white now in
the game it is
D6 If instead H6 is played this is where
we could see E5 working if the Knight
moves the pawn Falls and if you take
here this is where there's no longer a
check and white has time for this
winning shot Knight D5 Queen is hit
Bishop is hit Queen D6 is met with
Knight Tak Knight check and the queen
would
fall okay simple defense after Bishop
E2 small Pawn Center no E5 to worry
about okay castles Rook C8 what is a
thought or two what's an initial thought
or two you have when you see Rook to C8
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video maybe give this one 30
seconds okay I'm just going to share
some of my own thoughts my initial
thoughts when I see Rook
C8 on a half open
file and the queen there's some kind of
a pin going on the queen probably
doesn't feel so comfortable opposite The
Rook here's something more you can think
about once that King Rook has made a
move at the start of a chess game the
weakest square is
F7 given some development it goes from a
weakened Square to a strengthened
square right once castles is in there
The Rook is defending F7 but then a
little bit later on like right here move
14 that King Rook has moved F7 is back
to a weak
Square that's a natural progression in
the game it goes from weak strengthened
back to weak there's clearly something
that's going to happen in this game on
F7 anyhow I think it's helpful to
recognize uh that little progression
there okay coming up rook F to E1 last
pieces activated Central
here some regrouping going on these next
two moves by black and white the
followup Knight E7 the suggestion by the
engine is to go forward and of clog up
uh the E file B okay in other words
taking on these doubled pawns why
doesn't car Char may be playing this
way uh it does give white a majority on
the queen
side a much more static position ahead
probably wanted to keep it a bit more
lively all right he goes with Knight to
E7 both uh bishop and Rook are
unmasked this is a window of opportunity
for white this is vulnerable now white
goes after it with Knight to B5 and
opens up The Bishop's
eyes so how to defend
D6 in the game the Knight goes back to
E8 what's considered best is to move
this Knight allow the bishop to defend
but if you play in this way you're okay
with taking on doubled F pawns Carlson
was clearly not uh welcome to that so
what does he play in this position he
drops the Knight back
to E8 so these guys continue to compete
with one another you'll notice when
they're on these two squares competing
for these two Center points and this
move here black mimics it goes to E8 and
yet again they continue to fight for
these uh same
squares okay who benefits with these
last two moves Knight B5 Knight E8 it's
clearly white White's moving forward
Black's running in
Reverse okay white has promoted a piece
black has demoted a piece we continue
now in comes another knight move Knight
G5
creates uh some there's some tactics now
right around the corner we can see
pressure on F7 and H7 we might now start
to think about these two points is
unprotected one attacker one defender on
each
point actually there's a third now that
I look at it three unprotected points a
lot of pressure with this one move also
notice the queen she's sandwiched
between the black Rooks she has no moves
at all
currently right around the corner for
white is this idea to push E5 and
there'd already be a mate
threat okay this is one of the downsides
with retreating the Knight there's this
sensitivity now on the H7
Square in the game Knight G6 is played
however what's important to note is that
if the Knight is given a kick on this
move 18 there would follow Knight takes
F7 and then E5 and two things are
happening one there's pressure on D6
three times and if that's defended with
let's say D5 trying to close the
position position white also would have
this quiet but deadly Queen
H7 which cuts off the king from
returning to Safe ground and this would
by white time to swarm in on the attack
one for instance Bishop E2 Bishop
H5 completely
crushing we continue in this game with
Knight G
six the followup
E5 so this is a excellent followup here
in fact after Knight G5 this was already
considered a winning move move 18 Knight
G5 what's going on here well here's the
simplest one to look at Knight takes
Pawn would be game
over uh what other options are there in
the game D5 is played if you take on E
E5 this is very
painful the Queen's toast she doesn't
have a square you have to block with the
Knight okay completely winning for white
same story here take the bishop winning
the
king so in this game it is
D5 Queen B3 out of the
pin we continue Bishop to E7 instead of
Bishop E7 if H6 the followup would be
the same and that is Knight takes
F7 winning shot
here King takes
Knight Pawn takes
pawn and what do you what do you try in
this
position the followup is Bishop takes
Pawn if you try to attack the Knight the
Knight can hop into D6 some capture on
that square white would still have a
pick you could take it in either
direction the position is opening up for
these two cannons right in the center
look at these guys not doing anything
this position is officially broken
down what is played Bishop takes on
D5 that's not going to hold up The Rook
takes Bishop with this sequence with
this position we now
have uh a two pawns versus rook in
bounds but how good is this
Rook doesn't even have a move check on
board only one reply King f8 the queen
and Knight a killer combo white is
pouncing now on the light
squares big threat with Knight E6 how do
you deal with that in the game it's
Knight
F4 uh what other tries are there
here if let's say the bishop goes to H4
or E8
preparing to meet a check with King to
E7 well first of all this isn't a stable
Square you could always give the bishop
a kick let's say the bishop is on this
Square here's how you can continue a
check in regardless of where the King
goes Knight G5 is crushing let's stay
off of this diagonal King here Knight
here how you stopping
this Knight in the corner this is
beginning to look like Fisher random
chess
this would be mate too check
checkmate okay what other variation is
worth noting here again the move in the
game Knight F4 if you try Knight
C7 this doesn't work it hits the queen
and defends Knight E6 but white would
have Queen F3
check and what are Black's
options if the King goes back home white
continued to build up the pressure
Bishop
C4 looking at this if he try to defend
with Knight h8 there's Knight F5 all the
white pieces are swarming in there is no
defense and what would happen if the
king went to the castled square G8 well
now would come Knight C6 hitting the
queen any counter punch against White's
Queen with Rook f8 or Knight H4 can both
be met with Queen B3 check and then the
Queen the black queen would
fall what's the problem after Queen B7
Knight takes Bishop check and the queen
would be won
next so this is not working what's tried
Knight F4 Queen F3 Knight is pinned no
saving
it G5 there's G3 Carlson makes a run for
it now we're not even as white White's
not even down material at this stage
it's a light Square bishop and two pawns
for The Rook but again how good is that
Rook all right this one finishes up
quickly a 31 move game Queen B7 Knight
F5 paves the way for Bishop C4
check B5 The Queen Is Now overloaded has
to watch over the pawn and Bishop white
can simply take on B5 does take on B5
the bishop is
poison Queen takes Bishop would be met
with Knight takes Bishop check King in
the corner Queen f8
mate so on this one it's Bishop
f8 Bishop C4 check King h8 final move of
this game Knight
H6 black
resigns What's Happening Here we have a
main one threat how do you deal with
that if you play Queen E7 this is
considered the the best try but it's
still completely losing white could
continue with a check and even take some
time out to tuck the bishop away and you
could wait to deliver a discovered
check if let's say A5 in this position
there's Knight G5 discovered check and
even a sacrifice on H7 looking to next
go for a Rook lift there is no defense
to this
play anything else here's a fun one if
Bishop to E7 white could play Queen F7
and how does black stop Queen G8 mate
with the knight move everybody would
love to see this one Queen G8 followed
up with Knight F7 for a smothered mate
simply no defense after Knight H6
what did you think of this
one anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comments section below I hope you
enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care
bye